ديف هولويل ، أحب
اليوم
الكبير
[موسيقى] ، مرحباً يا
أبي ،
أنت جيد ، كيف حالك ،
آه ، ما الذي تفعله ،
شكرًا لك ، لقد قررت أن أجعله صوتًا مميزًا وكانت
النكتة مثل جعل والدي
مشهورًا
وواصلت الأمر  النشر عندما
كان في المستشفى جعلني ذلك نوعًا ما
عاقلًا وأردت حقًا أن
يعرف الناس من هو والدي ،
لم تتغير القدرة الفنية تمامًا عندما عاد إلى المنزل من
المستشفى العام الماضي ،
بدأ الرسم مرة أخرى
[موسيقى]
في عام 2018 بدأ  هذا المشروع الذي كان
يخطط له لمدة 20 عامًا ،
هذه المساحة بأكملها هي جعلها
شخصًا واحدًا يشاهده من مكان واحد في
وسط الغرفة
بلغة أجنبية تم تجنيبها بأعجوبة ،
إنها مجرد مقدمة إنه أمر لا يصدق ، أعني
أنه يفعل كل
ما فعله  قبل إطلاق النار بالضبط على
متجر بقالة pool Drive ، فأنت تعلم أنه يفعل
كل شيء